California has just established a new
program the program is called ebony
alerts and the purpose of ebony alerts
is to warn people about black
children actually more than black
children who have gone missing now you
might say well that's kind of a weird
program why why would they have ebony
alerts when we already have Amber Alerts
Amber Alerts are designed to alert
people to any child who has gone missing
any child of any race you get an alert
on your phone we've all gotten them then
you look out and try to find match the
car or match the description and a lot
of children are found this way
California though has established ebony
alerts to prioritize searches for
missing black children so if a white
child and a black child go missing in
California they're going to say forget
about the white child the black child
that's the one you got to find first the
black child is much much more important
than the white child but it's even
crazier than that because the ebony
alerts don't
only warn you of of searches for missing
children it's also for young adults not
even all that young adults so for an
amber alert the the child has to be
under 17 usually there are a few
different variations of it but it's
basically for for children who are under
17 for the ebony alert it's to alert
people to missing black persons age 12
to
25 so in in California now if a a white
5-year-old goes missing and a black 25y
old doesn't show up his parents don't
know where he
is the the black 25-year-old according
to the premise of the ebony alert will
be
prioritized over the white
5-year-old does that make a lot of sense
to
you if a white child and a black adult
go missing the black adult gets law
enforcement
priority don't forget I know it's a
little confusing Amber Alerts aren't
only for white people Amber Alerts are
for everybody but that wasn't good
enough for the libs they say no no we
need to we need to make sure that we
deprioritize white children who go
missing we need to make sure that we
give special priority to black children
really really ugly stuff but but there's
nothing surprising about
it we live at a time when white people
and to a lesser degree Asian people are
discriminated against legally in
practice they discriminated against
there is de facto racial discrimination
against whites but there is also deure
discrimination against whites through
affirmative action which was just
recently weakened by the Supreme Court
but then all the institutions that
practice affirmative action just came
out and said oh well we'll keep doing it
we'll just hide it we'll hide the racial
discrimination in the personal statement
or somewhere else so that exists and
what's so ironic about it is that at the
same time we are told that there is
de facto and even deura discrimination
against black people that's the premise
of black lives matter that's the premise
of all of this leftist activism that
innocent black people are being hunted
down the LA Times published a couple
days ago black people are fleeing
America that's obviously not true three
million black people have immigrated
into the United States over roughly the
last 20 years it's it's completely the
opposite of the truth but that's what we
come to expect when when you hear a
story from the establishment news media
or from entertainment or from Academia
you can be pretty confident that not
only is what they are telling you not
true but the opposite is true just go
check out the ebony alert laws right now
go to Tommy john.com it's fall which
means cozy nights in with the family and
thanks to our friends at Tommy John
loungewear for a night in is the
absolute best it could possibly be it's
got The Perfect Blend of comfort and
breathability Tommy John loungewear has
a level of softness that you have never
felt before their incredibly soft
loungewear is designed to envelop you in
a world of pure luxury I don't want to
get a little TMI here necessarily but
I'm just telling you I've I've worn many
boxer shorts over the course of my life
Tommy John it's the best the best
quality it feels the best it's just
absolutely magnificent their loungewear
is magnificent as well you are so much
more comfortable in Tommy John that you
can do everything better they've got
dozens of comfort Innovations breathe
lightweight moisture wicking fabric four
times the stretch of competing brands
that can keep you 7° cooler than cotton
every purchase is backed by Tommy John's
best pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee get 20% off your first order
right now at Tommy john.com
that's 20% off at Tommy john.com seite
for details California going to hell in
a hand basket that's been happening for
a long time even the former Governor of
California is admitting this now the
governator anold is saying that
the the new democrat campaign line is
that they want to f up every city in
America here he is on Rob Lowe's podcast
okay let me ask you this and I ask
people this all the time David drer good
friend of ours yes and a a good man
served for for many many many years he
used to have the greatest what makes me
a Republican and he had I think four or
five things I think it was um in no
particular strong military low taxes
less government more personal freedoms
there might have been one a couple but
it makes sense to know strong law
enforcement strong law enforcement and
and then I'd like to know what the I
always ask Democrats what it means to be
a democrat in that way and I think
whatever anybody would say cities what
would what they what would they say ruin
your cities what's that ruin your cities
ruin your cities that's what the
Democrats would say we about ruining the
cities we want to up every city in
America that's what the it seems to be
the theme right now why is that I have
no idea I have no idea but that is and
that's it and he's totally right that is
the implicit campaign slogan of every
Democrat hey elect us and we're going to
completely f up your city and everything
is going to go to hell and crime is
going to go skyrocketing and your kids
are going to be indoctrinated and abused
and you're not going to trust the
security of your property or anything
else we're going to fep up your cities
that's true and this is a fine attack
Republicans
can use this but it's not going to be
the best attack I think on Democrats and
the reason for that is Republicans don't
win in cities we had one major city in
the United States Jacksonville and we
lost that right we they have a Democrat
mayor now Republicans don't win in
cities we don't even really live in
cities I have lived in
cities lived in New York I've lived in
La I live in Nashville which is a
smaller City but it's
growing I do
there are some I'm not saying there are
none but that's not where we win and a
lot of Republicans who live in suburban
and rural
areas actually kind of get a kick out of
it I
think at some level when the cities go
up to Hell in a hand basket because it
confirms their beliefs about Democrat
policies and about the nature of the
Cities so I don't think that's going to
be the best
attack it's a it's a fine line it's a
fine observation but I think the better
attack is going to be on something like
parental rights I think that is probably
the best line of attack that Republicans
have right now it's what got Glenn yunan
elected in Virginia it's what made Ronda
santis it's in part what made Ronda
santis very popular in Florida it works
anywhere it works in blue counties it
works in red counties works in the
country and it works in the cities boy
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey hey hey hey ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time